we recently saw a in the city of san
francisco a purchase of 20 000 garbage
cans i'm sure you saw that i saw that
how does something like that happen
i i think it's a little i read that and
i had the same thought this is
spectacularly insane um
what i heard is it was a pilot to test
out auto compacting trash technology and
so it's a bit of a journalist's story
making us a stink there's a lot of
things to make us think about cleaning
up the streets and and beautifying the
city being one uh yeah excuse the pun um
but running a pilot i actually think
that's what we want our governments to
do be more innovative and so it's
they're operating in glass houses with
everyone throwing stones at them so it's
an extremely difficult operating
environment i'll give you a couple
examples i'm running an enterprise
software company
i don't take a software purchase to for
my board to approve we've got an amazing
board one of the best boards mark
andreessen john chambers joe lonsdale
they'd laugh me out of the room if i
took you want to buy an extra few sales
force licenses but believe it or not
most of our nation's governments
local governments have to take
certain purchases to their board for
approval
it's crazy and then everyone sits around
and
throws stones at that why are you doing
this why are you doing that imagine
running a company like that or imagine
running a company where a journalist is
going to be writing up you want to do
this for your product feature
that's it that's a very difficult
operating environment so i don't know
the specifics on the 20 000 trash cans
but when i started reading they're
running a pilot and it's technology that
auto compacts i said still sounds crazy
but it sounds a little less it's not
it's not a rubber could be fake news
could be the press trying to get a
headline it does have an interesting an
auto compacting garbage can but also
seems incredibly wasteful i think what i
heard is we're trying out four or five
of these and if it works they'd still be
unbelievably expensive maybe a couple
thousand a piece what else is expensive
paying a salaries benefits and
retirement for people to walk around and
run around and drive trucks around the
city picking up the trash pretty darn
expensive to maintain our parks our
roads to haul trash to cut trees it's
unbelievable if you think about it but
these are real people and they get paid
and it's massive expenses and so i
assume they're trying to innovate to
actually cut costs in the long term
doesn't mean they're doing a good job
but there's a lot more to a lot of these
stories than people realize
what government in the world is the most
efficient that you've modeled the
software or the strategies and best
practices on that you try to educate
people here i'm sure you've done some
studies of hey how does it done in
finland or norway or tokyo or whatever
high functioning sydney comes to mind
city and you try to bring those lessons
back here so we're focused domestically
on the us
we see a lot of interesting and
innovative stuff going on the the city
of tucson arizona for instance the city
of tampa is
tucson is using our budgeting and
planning to streamline the massive
collaboration required to spend a
billion dollars a year across a whole
range of services and departments city
of tampa is working really hard on
dashboards performance metrics so you
can start to understand if we're going
to pay this much for these services what
are we getting back and trying to run
the city with some outcome orientation
what's an example of that outcome and
metrics that sounds fascinating to me is
actually holding
how holding the government accountable
for outcomes
seems like a a great idea of course it
is more red tape and it is more
infrastructure exactly there's a
trade-off on these things jason and it's
re it's more complicated than we want to
admit you need to mow parks okay how
many freaking mowers and how many acres
are being mowed per week and at some
point it's useful and then another point
it's like all right this is we we don't
measure any companies at this level of
detail so how do we do just enough and
not too much because at some point
you've got people walking around with
clipboards all day as opposed to doing
the actual work but there's a mountain
of things to be measured from tree
trimming the number of road miles paved
to the number of potholes paved to the
number of business licenses issued to
the revenue that's driving to the
outdoor dining permits to the speed of
response on citizens i could go on and
on another great government that we work
with is the state of idaho the state of
west virginia these are
governments really focused on
accountability on transparency and on
responsiveness to to their citizens tell
me about the one at a time because
you're going pretty fast there the one
i'm i'm interested in there is
transparency how does transparency uh
manifest itself in this case go to the
state of idaho do a quick search either
on google or the government's website
and you can pull up powered by opengov
every single dollar that the state has
spent every single dollar over the past
if i remember correctly five or ten
years you can find out what it went to
where it goes what it was for so when
we're talking transparency we're talking
basically an open ledger on the website
correct and it's is it in real time
it's nightly
wow it's no it's unbelievable it's a
huge number of transactions
billions and billions of dollars this is
the state of idaho you can do the same
state of idaho correct
and so i wonder are journalists now or
people who are competing for that
business now able to see where the
money's flowing and then
report on it or compete on it have you
seen examples of that where this
transparency led to either more
competition or or reducing corruption i
guess the act of just publishing it
makes it easier to steal
you mean harder
i'm sorry harder to seal yes much harder
yes it makes it easier to stop
corruption is i guess what i was doing
we hear unbelievable anecdotes from a
journalist or saying wow you just saved
me
hours and days of my life pulling
information on budgets and expenditures
you you hear citizens they'll go to
their council or legislative meetings
and say thank you like i trust you more
you're putting it out there for us to
analyze and see
we've had stories where we've actually
uncovered discrepancies that turned out
to be serious problems and the
government found corruption or fixed
example we had in the state of ohio our
data and our technology helped the
attorney general of ohio find a price
fixing scheme for road salt sounds funny
sounds odd but there were two major
players if i remember correctly
and they were colluding which is against
i think either state or federal
anti-trust laws or some price fixing
laws and they found it doing analysis
through the data that was published
through opengov
and so
we talked about transparency what were
and then you also talked about response
time
where would that response time be seen
and are people actually recording the
response time for i don't know 9-1-1
3-1-1 and then publishing it
so
they actually a lot of data is being
published on response time public safety
is a whole space unto itself you could
say that opengov is the leader in public
administration software public safety
does the computer-aided dispatch and the
records management for jails and arrests
and other things it's a big an exciting
space itself
those response times are frequently
published on opengov dashboards and and
stories pages and transparency there's
all sorts of other types of response
times for instance if you're a vendor or
a developer or contractor in the
community what's the response time for
for getting a permit issued what's the
response time for opening a business or
getting a liquor license what's the
response time for i want to bid on
something the government needs i'm a
purveyor of road salt and i want a fair
competition to sell my freaking product
can i compete can you tell me how to
compete can you get back to me if i'm
the low bidder or the best value and so
open gov procurement streamlines all of
that for the the vendors and the
developers that are trying to compete
for business and grow business in the
communities
before we get to the ad read i want you
to go to linkedin.com unicorn and post
your first job for free at linkedin jobs
that's right a free job posting from
linkedin jobs your founders you're
running a company you need to get talent
in there to help you out because your
company is growing and you're so busy
time spent searching for and
interviewing the wrong candidates for a
job opening is wasted time you could be
putting that into your customers your
product your team and your vision that's
why linkedin jobs has made it easier to
get the candidates worth interviewing in
front of you and they do it so fast you
can create a job post in minutes on
linkedin and reach the world's largest
professional network of over
750 million
people focus on the candidates with the
skills and the experience you need and
use screening questions to get your role
in front of the most qualified people
then use the simple tools that are built
into linkedin jobs to quickly filter and
prioritize who you want to interview and
hire we love linkedin jobs here at
launch and this week in startups we
hired a third producer we're going to
hire a fourth we got a curriculum
designer working on founder.university
which is going to be a 12-week program
every week 40 million job seekers visit
linkedin you get your first job listing
for free that's right free f-r-e-e
linkedin.com unicorn linkedin.com
unicorn to post that job for free terms
and conditions do apply because they're
giving you something for free